more and more agreements have been
reached by the nfl and the nfl players
association
i believe that by the end of this week
early next week they'll have everything
buttoned up on all points so that's
encouraging they are getting it done
because the time for getting it done has
arrived whether it is the safety
protocols or
the lingering issues with economics but
one one item of old business from
yesterday that i wrote about at
profootballtalk.com got some information
about the league's position on this and
this is something that i think is an
important intersection between football
and society the aggressive testing the
thousands of tests that will be
performed on completely asymptomatic
players coaches etc as a
preventive mechanism
right
what kind of strain will that create on
the resources in the various communities
that are currently
completely under siege when it comes to
the virus and you have thousands of
local residents who need tests who think
they may have it who want to get it
turned around so they can make decisions
about what they need to do what
treatment do they need
how how
sequestered should they be from the rest
of society for the next week or two
weeks
and the league's belief chris
and and i understand this conceptually
the league's belief
is that because it has arranged with
bioreference laboratories a national
testing firm
and bioreference laboratories has
actually created capacity to serve the
nfl this isn't capacity that would have
been available for anybody else because
of the profit motive that private
business engages in all the time and
bioreference laboratories is owned by a
company that's publicly traded there's a
profit motive there it isn't some
governmental entity that's there to
serve people it's there to serve private
business interests it's part of the
capitalist society that we live in
because the nfl is paying them
they're setting up the capacity and
because it's all done nationally it's
not like you've got the miami dolphins
going to some local hospital
and and boxing out
people who need
19 tests in south florida right this is
a separate national system that was
specifically created for the nfl that
the nfl is paying for the borrower
reference laboratories is making it
available because the nfl's paying for
it so it's self-contained and it's not
putting any
any drain on the system right that's
that's they're saying do you believe
that do you think that's real well
i i here's here's where it potentially
falls apart right
and and and i think that the league
would acknowledge this
as long as
nationally we're not in a crisis right
as it relates to getting tests
conducted and turned around chris yeah
then we're okay right we've got hot
spots where people are waiting five to
seven days or longer to get results
because they're in an area where there's
so many people who need tests and we
need test test test test tests i mean i
was watching
morning joe before we got started today
and one of the points they made is by
the time we get the cold and flu season
the national system will be overrun
then what happens it's scary get a
24-hour turnaround right if you if
you're the nfl so you know and and i
think there's an acknowledgement
that the nfl would make if push came to
shove that if the national system is
under sufficient duress
then
the league does fall behind
critical care patients health care
workers the people who need that 24-hour
turnaround and they get it first right
before the nfl and then maybe we go to
48 or 72 hours which which makes the
whole testing concept collapse onto
itself if you can't get the results
quickly because you don't want guys who
are
in the facility on the field in games
that were tested two days ago and you
haven't got the results yet and for all
you know they may be positive yeah well
i mean this is why as a country we got
to get a hold of this thing for not just
the nfl but just for all economic
reasons i mean if we want to get going
and get back to normal and all those
things yeah of course but you know yeah
when you look at it at first look and
i'm glad you explained it that way
because you do you you think about
okay yeah it's a private company they
got money to spend they got to come in
their way but all right you know is it
really the better thing for society and
yeah we know that right now it's
certainly surging around the country but
it's only a few states that really are
having huge issues or starting to get
overwhelmed in their hospital systems
and things like that to where uh you
know okay i'll buy it right now that
it's a national thing and it's not
cutting into the issues that we're
seeing in those states i hope that's the
truth i do but i think that's the worry
mike is kind of what you said there at
the end i just i just worry well
i guess the bottom line is if we get to
that point as a country again we're in
trouble anyways and of course then i
would expect football not to be able to
work or or make it make it capable of
happening let alone a lot of other
businesses and things too
and i think again
isn't entirely accurate because we
haven't been to that point yet yeah i
know that's what i mean right we had a a
couple of of specific locations that
were in an emergency situation whether
it was washington state new york city
early on
and those got under control but now
you've got these other areas primarily
sun belt where
the virus is out of control
and
if we don't get it under control before
it ends up spreading and getting out of
control in other areas that's when you
get the drain on the national testing
resources and that's when bioreference
laboratories may throw its hands in the
air and say we just can't keep up with
this we don't have the supplies we don't
have the capacity we don't have the
ability to give people 24-hour
turnaround unless they are critical care
patients or health care workers and the
nfl with its predominantly healthy
workforce no longer gets dibs we no
longer can do this we must provide these
services to others who are in greater
need that's where it potentially falls
apart now now there's a there's a a
silver lining in the dark cloud that
could be looming for the nfl when we get
to cold and flu season and that is the
race to get to the point where they
develop highly accurate point of care
testing chris yeah testing means you
don't send it off to a lab you've got a
device where you swab your mouth you
prick your finger you get a result and
right now they have it it's available
the problem is it's not accurate it's
used in hospital settings you can get a
result in 15 minutes to an hour
but the technology hasn't advanced to
the point where the off-site testing has
the bio-reference laboratory accuracy
rate right now i'm told is 98 to 99
percent which is damn good you'd like a
hundred yeah you settle for 99 or 98
right when we talk about the point of
care testing i'm told it's 80 to 85
percent that's not good enough so
they're hoping that
the
the work and the research and the
advances that are all happening kind of
behind the scenes and people aren't
really talking about it but that the
point of care testing will catch up from
an accuracy standpoint and there'll be
enough point-of-care tests that the nfl
can just shift to that which would be
great because if we could get to the
point well
all players and all coaches could could
know within 15 minutes to an hour on any
given day whether they're positive or
negative you solve a hell of a lot of
the problems yes the nfl is is risking
here that you're going to have somebody
who's who's walking around the facility
or running around on the field shedding
virus all over other people yeah that
would be a game changer i mean you're
right i mean it just it just limits the
the amount of consequences that can
happen and things that can happen uh on
a daily basis so that would be amazing
now do we think like you know is there
going to be a national call for those
type of tests too though to where you
know okay i'm just bringing this up you
know okay now these tests are available
the general public's going to get them
first so you know certain you know how
is this going to work out too i just so
i don't know if we can depend on that
right now right is basically what we're
saying we're hopeful that'll certainly
make things is certainly easier but i
don't know i just uh i wouldn't i
wouldn't put all my chips or my eggs in
that basket if i'm the nfl
here's reality yeah first the technology
has to get there and then the capacity
has to catch up and and
these are all things we've kind of taken
for granted in the past
like in an emergency situation you
assume
that
someone
out there
presumably people who have our tax
dollars
will
press the big red button that gets it
done
that you know we need 50 million of
these tests boom we're going to get 50
million of these tests we're going to
pay whatever we have to do we're going
to fire up whatever engines we have to
fire up and whatever factories we have
to fire up and if we don't have the
factories we're going to build the
factories and we're going to get it done
you know the kind of urgency and this is
before either of our time but during a
world war what happened right they
pressed the big red button and everybody
did everything they had to do to get
what we needed to prevail and i think
that's been the one
lingering frustration and you mentioned
it from time to time and i'm trying to
kind of articulate what you're feeling
and a lot of other people are feeling
yeah where's the big red button right
press to get exactly what we need to
beat this thing like why are we in this
weird kind of dream
state where it's like when are we gonna
wake up right i feel like that's where
we are we know we're dreaming we know
it's a nightmare and we're trying to
wake the hell up and we can't
well you know you know unfortunately as
americans we're stubborn i mean we are
and you know and for whatever reason
that is we're we're the kind of group of
people that you know has got to get
punched in the face once or twice to
realize that something's real you know i
i get it you know i understand oh you
know at first when i heard about covet
19 and everything like that oh yeah okay
it's a little scary blah blah blah but
i'll be okay no big deal you know but
then hey up here in the new york area
you start to know people and hear people
that you know and you know they're
getting sick they're dying blah blah
blah there's i don't mean to say blah
blah blah to be insensitive but you
start to hear the horror stories that
makes you straighten up and
unfortunately i don't know why but the
rest of the country just didn't believe
that we were going through this up there
and now they're kind of taking their
lumps so
hopefully uh it does get figured out you
know i don't know about the big red
button thing i've lost hope with that
because i think we should have hit the
big red button a long time ago and uh it
just doesn't seem like we're working as
a unified country right now which of
course makes it very hard to be unified
in everything and get businesses going
and get everything back on the right
track so
i don't know where it goes and that's
just the frustrating thing especially
with football but but unfortunately our
country does have something to do with
this as well
and just to put a button on that notion
i think the problem is and this is why i
say there will be a special place in
hell for these people folks in
government folks in media who have spent
the last five months doing everything
they can to downplay downplay downplay
downplay that has influence on the
average person because they would prefer
it to be downplayed they don't want to
have dramatic adjustments to their life
they don't want to take things seriously
that would affect in a very significant
way what they do how they behave what
they wear on their faces how close they
stand to friends neighbors and relatives
they want to hear people in supposed
positions of influence tell them it's no
big deal right it's no big deal and then
five months later
we're at a point where it's probably
time for us all to wake up from this
nightmare and say it is a big deal let's
hit the red button let's do what we need
to do for the good of everyone and also
so we can have football i mean obviously
and and look that it's more important
that we beat this thing
as a nation
but at the same time we also want
football and football i think is part of
the overall emotional and mental and
healing that we need as a people and
hopefully it all kind of comes together
and hopefully we hit the big red button
and we move
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports